mais c'est vrai qu'on rêve tous en ce
moment tous les journalistes suis pas
journaliste mais j'aimerais quand même y
interviewait richard virenque on
aimerait en savoir un peu plus d'abord
parce que jugée aussi à mon avis le juge
c'est déjà plus de choses que nous alors
si j'avais richard virenque en face de
moi je dirais écouter on a lu cette
semaine dans les journaux que c'est
votre épouse stéphanie virenque qui
allaient chercher les produits préparés
par le fameux docteur mabuse alors la
question que vous pose c'est est ce que
quand elle va faire des courses et il
revient chargé elle aussi il paraît que
le docteur mabuse aurait soigné sa jeudi
dans la presse cette semaine aussi entre
entre autres des cyclistes mais aussi
françois mitterrand à une époque le
fameux monsieur fiennes il a soigné
mitterrand et catherine deneuve alors
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est grâce
au dopage qu'elle a réussi à monter deux
fois les marches cette année l écoute et
richard virenque géant fait lu dans les
journaux vous avez reconnu avoir pris
c'est uniquement ce qui l'a reconnu à
vous avez uniquement reconnu avoir pris
que des gouttes blanche dpu vertes et
des comprimés bleus pas de mal ça prouve
au moins vous savez reconnaître les
couleurs mais pourquoi vous avez du mal
avec les avocats marrons est il vrai que
pour gagner du temps le dr mabuse vous a
proposé de remplacer directement la
selle par une seringue ça s'écrit sûr
que j'aimerais vous poser chez pas si
vrai progrès le docteur mabuse qui
soigne des shows alors je demanderai à
richard virenque écouté puisque le
docteur mabuse soigner des chevaux aussi
dit moi c'est vraiment une différence
parce qu'à un cheval sans selle
il est heureux tandis qu'un coureur sans
sel ça fait quand même un peu mal au cul
au départ alors on a dit que la
différence
on a dit que la différence entre un
séjour de jeunesse euro ont dit que la
différence entre un cheval et un
cycliste c'est chez les chevaux il ya
encore des pur sang
est ce que c'est vrai et on n'y aura pas
beaucoup de coureurs sur le tour de
france l'été prochain alors est ce que
c'est vrai que si raymond poulidor
s'inscrivait à nouveau il aurait enfin
une chance de gagner
les souvenirs deuxième col et il
pourrait être est terrible c'est terminé
encore deuxième voyage il est vrai que
si les coureurs se dopent c'est pas pour
gagner mais c'est pouvoir sauter là pour
pouvoir sauter la miss qui les attend l
arrivée avec un bouquet de fleurs parce
qu'avec a toujours une fille âge à la
champagne de deux filles we are
généralement le son de we 2,6 g des
bouquets c'est pour cette mère n'a
jamais compris je pense que c'est pour
ça qu'ils se dopent
et puis à la dernière question que je
demanderai à richard virenque sait
écouter plutôt que vous dopez pour faire
du vélo du vélo vous n'avez jamais pensé
acheter directement immobile at il est
le capitaine